aujourd'hui ferdinand tennis communauté
et société
la référence du biographique à la base
de cette vidéo introduction à la
sociologie par sept grands auteurs de
nathalie rigaux en 1887 ferdinand tennis
va proposer de distinguer la communauté
de la société la communauté est un
processus traditionnels tandis que la
société et le processus moderne issu de
l'industrialisation des sociétés de
l'époque la communauté concept de guy
mannschaft en allemand et en fait vu
sous l'angle de la proximité une
proximité qui peut être affectif social
ou spatial les individus qui participent
à la communauté en un sentiment d'unité
et se comprennent mutuellement
puisqu'ils ont les même objectif la même
volonté commune
en ce sens ils obéissent tous aux
objectifs fixés par la communauté
ferdinand sioniste va dire qu'ils ont
des biens communs des mots comme un des
amis communs et des ennemis communs il
ira même jusqu'à dire que la communauté
poussé au bout de sa logique conduire à
la destruction de tous ceux qui sont
extérieurs à celle ci
les exemples de communautés sont
nombreux encore aujourd'hui les liens de
voisinage les liens familiaux ou les
liens qui nous lie à une nation ou à un
pays sont tous des liens qui sont fondés
sur ce principe de communautés en
opposition à cette communauté nous avons
le concept de société diesel charte dans
la société les individus sont pris dans
leur unité et dans leur individualité
ils poursuivent tous un intérêt
personnel ils sont indépendants des uns
les autres et finalement fonctionne
toujours selon une rationalité une
rationalité qui est calculatrice la
raison est très importante dans la
société
évidemment cette société découle sur une
vision très matérialiste des rapports
sociaux
la logique commerciale où la logique
marchande et celle vraiment
va fonder les relations entre les
individus dans la société
l'individu finalement est opposé aux
autres ou en tout cas à tous ceux qui ne
pourraient pas rencontré l'intérêt
individuel
cette société a tendance à être
universel dans le sens où ces liens
étant tout à fait dépouiller de toute
connotation subjectif puisque on est
juste sur des rapports de rationalité
temps à être global et à s'imposer à
tous dans les liens de société on va
retrouver tous ces éléments qui vont
dans le sens de la marchandisation des
rapports sociaux
tout est permis grâce à l'argent qui
devrait un vraiment le médium de
rencontre de l'autre dans le film in the
air avec george clooney d'urss cluny
avec un un personnage qui voyagent dans
le monde entier qui prend régulièrement
l'avion qui n'a pas l'occasion de créer
réellement des liens sociaux de
communauté et donc tous ces rapports
sont basées sur des rapports marchands
et il n'est reconnu que par sa carte de
crédit
finalement et cartes de fidélité qu'il a
dans les différentes compagnies
d'aviation ou dans les différents palace
qu'ils fréquentent